هدوء في جبهات القتال شمال سوريا يرافقه
ثبات لخطوط التماس منذ توقف المعارك بين
قوات النظام السوري وقوات المعارضه في
مارس اذار من عام 2022
تهدئه عسكريه هي الاطول اندلاع الثوره
السوريه جاءت نتيجه تفاهمات بين الجانبين
الروسي والتركي وافضت الى اتفاق لوقف
اطلاق النار في ادلب
يسري الاتفاق رغمات الثنائيه بشان حزمه من
القضايا بينها الانتشار العسكري والممر
الامني وحركه التجاره والنقل وهو ما تتضرع
به روسيا لقصف المرافق الخدميه والطبيه
والاقتصاديه في ادلب بين الحين والاخر في
محاوله للضغط على الجانب التركي حسب
قياديين في قوات المعارضه
الجنود العسكري على الارض شماليه سوريا لم
يصاحبه تقدم في العمليه السياسيه خارج
الحدود حيث تشهد تعطيلا مستمرا مع تعدد
مساراتها بتعدد الدول الضامنه لها على مر
اثني عشر عاما من الثوره
بدات العمليه السياسيه في سوريا في اطارها
الدولي مع مؤتمر جنيف منتصف عام 2012 وبني
على بيانات مؤتمر جينيف قرار مجلس الامن
22/54 عام 2015 الذي يضع اطارا عاما
لخريطه الانتقال السياسي في البلاد تعثر
هذا المسار مع تبدل خريطه النفوذ العسكري
ولعب النظام السوري وحليفه روسيا وايران
على عامل الوقت وتقسيم مناطق نفوذ
المعارضه الى اربع مناطق لخفض التصعيد مع
بدء مسار استنابرعايه كل من روسيا وتركيا
وايران وبحضور وفدي المعارضه والنظام خسرت
قوات المعارضه خلال جولات استنا كلا من
حلبه ودمشقه ودرعا وحمص وجزءا كبيرا من
ريفي ادبه وحما وخلال مسار استانا لم تحقق
اللجنه الدستوريه التي يقودها السوريون
بتسهيل من الامم المتحده في جنيف اي تقدم
بشان صياغه دستور جديد للبلاد ولطالما
اتهمت هيئه التفاوض التابعه للمعارضه وفد
النظام السوري بتعطيل وعرقله عمل صياغه
الدستور وملف المعتقلين والمفقودين
تعاقب على اداره الملف السوري امميا منذ
عام 2012 خمسه مبعوثين دوليين اولهم مندوب
عن الجامعه العربيه واربعه مبعوثين امميين
اخرهم
ورغم المحاولات الامميه والدوليه للتوصل
الى تسويه او حل للنزاع كانت الامور على
الارض تتجه نحو تحقيق حلف ثلاثي بين تركيا
وروسيا وايران يمسك الملف السوري ويفرض
تسويات واتفاقيات بمعزل عن الامم المتحده
بعد 12 عاما وصلت الاحتياجات الانسانيه في
سوريا الى اعلى مستوياتها على الاطلاق حسب
الامم المتحده وساهم في ذلك استخدام روسيا
للفيتو في مجلس الامن لمنع صدور قرار
انساني بشان اليه تمديد ادخال المساعدات
الانسانيه التي يعتمد عليها اكثر من اربعه
ملايين نازح ومهجر شمالي البلاد يقول
السوريون ان الفيتو الروسي لطالما اضعف
دور مجلس الامن الدولي وكان سببا في اخفاق
المجتمع الدولي في حمايه الشعب السوري من
نظام الاسد مسارات سياسيه تعددت اسمائها
وطرق الحل فيها لانهاء النزاع في سوريا
الا ان كل ذلك بقي حبرا على ورق مع دعم
روسيا وايران المستمر لحملات النظام
السوري ضد قوات المعارضه السوريه ادام ابو
حسام الجزيره ادلب